joining me now is House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy congressman great to see
it tonight
today Pelosi you saw that clip was
visibly annoyed they're pressing her you
know when he gonna send the articles
what's going on and she she seems very
frustrated in this position
what's her calculation what's the pro
and con for her here well she has no car
I mean she's gonna fail at this she's
already failed and now it's not just
Republicans
it's Democrat senators but what's even
worse it's Dianne Feinstein this is her
home senator but it's her hometown
senator from San Francisco she literally
said if it's so urgent have you keep it
it loses his urgency either send it over
or don't send it at all it's crushing
her but what if the house decides on its
own can it to subpoena Bolton this this
theory has been floated or less 72 hours
they could just subpoena Bolton and get
information from him and kind of I don't
know backfill the impeachment inquiry
that's what they're saying now well they
had the opportunity they didn't think it
was important enough they thought it was
so urgent they thought they had enough
information but lo and behold when it
went to the floor the bipartisan vote
was no they know their case is so weak
it's almost like she doesn't want to sit
it like she's embarrassed of it all
right I want to get back to the Iran
issue congressman because Democrats came
out of the administration's briefings
today on Capitol Hill and we're all
pretty much singing the same tune watch
I was deeply surprised at the lack of
information presented by the
administration regarding a specific
imminence right there was no raw
evidence presented that there was an
imminent threat I was utterly
unpersuaded about any evidence about the
imminence of a threat that was new or or
compelling they all lying I mean Michael
Lee is essentially saying the same thing
as all these Democrats conservative from
Utah it is a top secret hearing but I
don't know what they're talking about
think for one moment to the American
public they don't have to be in that
meeting more than 600 American soldiers
have been killed by this individual they
killed an American they
took down a drone they bomb tankers they
bomb Saudi Arabia refinery they took
after our embassy and somehow it's us
escalating something I think the way the
president handled this is masterful it's
like a chess game and these people don't
even know what their table they are now
this socialist Democrats are defending
Iran over defending America Michael Lee
said it's the worst briefing he's ever
seen said it was basically stating
conclusory comments about the imminence
without actual facts of time place
manner what was going to happen and what
I wish I could share with you what was
said inside why do you think he's saying
that I do not know why he's saying that
I was not in the Senate briefing I was
in the House briefing must have been the
same as it was the same briefings the
same members from CIA secretary was a
briefers condescending that's why not at
all not at all
and what was interesting if I could only
share the way people would ask questions
and come back they would get the answer
they asked and they'd try to come back
select they couldn't hear it you asked a
question here it was answered well I
don't understand that it was
embarrassing because here they are they
want to defend this terrorist he said
he's a bad guy but I want to start
hearing Democrats say he's a bad guy
because he killed Americans because he
went after our embassy because he killed
another American because he went after
the tankers after employing the tactics
of the perpetual resistance for three
years now it's amazing to see and hear
the Democrats claiming that it's the
president who wants to divide the
country at a time like this but that's
exactly what happened Leon Panetta was
pretty well respected guy on with
Anderson Cooper let's watch this moment
of potential national unity and national
kind of relief he you know chose it to
kind of lay it on attack President Obama
she's almost deliberately tried to split
this country apart all he cares about is
whether or not his supporters continue
to support him I think that's a serious
mistake so did the president miss a
historic opportunity to bring the nation
together today congressman no I think
what he did was he made this world safer
think for a moment what if we were able
to stop bin Laden before 9/11 happened
now think about how many more people are
safe and think about what history will
look like in the future because how
strong this president acted he held
restraint when the drone went down but
when they killed American he had a red
line on the sand and he actually acted I
would say what if we could have knocked
out Saddam without going to war again
when he traveled to Kuwait well it would
have been nice and knock him out exactly
what's so interesting now they're going
to bring up a War Powers Act but this is
such a joke they are bringing in under
what is called a con resolute Amaro yeah
tomorrow
but you got to understand how they're
bringing it up it's a con resolution
this is the same type of resolution we
use to do a stop box derby on the
Capitol Hill it doesn't go to the
president it means nothing so they're
doing it too what for what no no to try
to appease a socialist base but it has
no power it has no meaning it's equal to
a soapbox derby but this is a
congressman Monalisa slot conjunto
should be embarrassed
she's Michigan this is a battleground
state watching in Michigan tonight this
is your congress someone let's play it
have you react we should as a body be
discussing and debating if there's even
the risk of us going into war with Iran
I just wanted to put the marker down and
be very very clear just because we're
past this moment doesn't mean the
Congress has a right to abdicate its
responsibilities very high-minded
congressman she knows better than this
if you read her background and you know
what's most interesting she's allowing
her name to be used as a trick it's a
resolution that means nothing it doesn't
go the president has no meaning
whatsoever and they're trying to play
something up and then they're trying to
tie the hands and are they forgetting
what Iran has done to the American
soldier what Iran has no she was she
served in Iraq and the CIA yes so she
understands she served her country
what is the speaker doing to these new
members first walking them off the cliff
on impeachment now getting them where
they're defending Iran over defending
America well the AOC plus-three they
were fun to watch but wait and watch
them laugh during the hearing we're
gonna get in there laughing as they're
taught as Sheila jackson-lee is actually
talking about casualties I'll give her
credit she was talking actual about
potential for casualties and the other
laughing in the background telling you
but remember these are the same
residuals that on 9/11 some people did
some things remember what she said about
nothing I can't think I already have a
stomachache tonight if I heard that
again I'd go right off the edge
congressman great deal Raymond Arroyo
coming up oh sorry